hola lo que voy a tratar de hacer en
este vídeo es aproximar el área bajo la
curva mientras fx nuestra función es
igual a x cuadrado más 1 entre los
intervalos donde x es igual a 1 y x es
igual a 3 entonces vamos a aproximar lo
construyendo 4 rectángulos bajo la curva
entonces comencemos pensando cómo
lucirían estos 4 rectángulos de dicha
función entonces tenemos este de aquí
primero que estoy trazando luego tenemos
un segundo por acá y finalmente un
cuarto en realidad si te das cuenta no
hemos definido a la altura de dichos
rectángulos todavía pero lo haremos más
adelante ahora hay que pensar en cómo
podríamos hacerle para poder decir que
dichos rectángulos tienen la misma base
vamos a llamar a esta parte de aquí esta
distancia
delta x entonces si te das cuenta
comenzamos en 1 y terminamos en 3
entonces será la diferencia de la
distancia entre el número total de
rectángulos que tenemos finalmente esto
nos da un medio entonces
x de cada uno de estos intervalos que
sería la base de nuestros rectángulos va
a hacer un medio entonces tendríamos
este de por aquí estarían 1.5 y nuestro
cuarto rectángulo y de 2.5 a 3 pero bien
ahora pensemos en cómo podríamos hacerle
para encontrar la altura de dichos
rectángulos eso nos vamos a enfocar en
este primer vídeo pues más adelante en
futuros vídeos veremos que hay otras
formas de realizar esto y entonces voy a
usar para dicho dicho cálculo de
nuestras alturas voy a utilizar el
límite izquierdo de los rectángulos para
encontrarla lo que haremos será evaluar
nuestra función en el límite izquierdo
como te darás cuenta para nuestro primer
rectángulo tenemos que ese punto del
límite izquierdo es 1 entonces sería efe
de uno para este primero luego en este
segundo vemos que estaba de 1.5 entonces
la parte de aquí sería la función
evaluada en 1.5
efe de 1.5 o sea la altura de nuestro
segundo rectángulo
luego pasando a nuestro tercer
rectángulo de la misma forma que lo
hicimos anteriormente también nos
fijamos en nuestro límite izquierdo de
este rectángulo y este punto de aquí
sería la función evaluada en 2
efe de 2 y aquí es donde tenemos nuestra
altura de nuestro tercer rectángulo y
finalmente pasando a nuestro cuarto
rectángulo solo sería la función
evaluada en 2.5 efe de 2.5 recuerda que
con todo esto simplemente nos fijamos en
nuestro límite izquierdo de cada
rectángulo y evaluamos así nuestra
función para obtener nuestra altura y
ahora lo hicimos de esta manera con la
finalidad de aproximar nuestra área
total debajo de la curva utilizando algo
de nuestros conocimientos de los
rectángulos y claramente esto será
simplemente una aproximación dado que
estamos dejando a un lado u omitiendo
estas pequeñas áreas que voy a colocar
por aquí de color rosa pero pues así es
simplemente es una aproximación muy
buena quizás
para calcular nuestra área debajo de
este de esta función entonces ahora sí
vamos si observamos cuál sería el área
que nos está dando cada uno de estos
rectángulos tendríamos que la base y la
altura se multiplican entonces la altura
de nuestro primer rectángulo es f
evaluada en uno por delta x más la
altura de nuestro segundo rectángulo es
f de 1.5 por la base que es delta x
luego tenemos nuestro tercer rectángulo
que vuelve a ser f
nuestra función evaluada en 2 más
nuestra función evaluada en 2 por delta
x estoy utilizando colores diferentes
para que se quede claro entonces
finalmente calculando el área de nuestro
cuarto rectángulo de nuestro último
rectángulo voy a utilizar el color
naranja precisamente por lo que estaba
comentando entonces sería más
efe la función evaluada en 2.5 por delta
x y en general esta es nuestra
aproximación del área bajo la curva de
nuestra función
pero bueno entonces cuál es dicho valor
veamos qué es nuestra función evaluada
en cada uno de los extremos izquierdos
de nuestros rectángulos por delta x
donde delta x será un medio entonces la
función de evaluada en uno es igual a
uno al cuadrado más uno es dos por un
medio más la función evaluada en 1.5 1.5
al cuadrado es 2.25 más uno es 3.25 3.25
por un medio que dentro del delta x más
la función evaluada en 2-2 al cuadrado
es 4 más 15 por un medio y finalmente la
función evaluada en 2.5 entonces 2.5 al
cuadrado es 6.25 + 6.25 que es la
función de valor al cuadrado más 1 7.25
por un medio
y solo para facilitarnos las cuentas
vamos a factorizar el un medio de toda
nuestra de todas nuestras tumbas lo voy
a poner en diferente color ahora veamos
si calculamos todo esto de adentro de
una forma mental entonces tenemos que
sería 2 + 3.25 + 5 + 7.25 y tratemos de
calcularlo mentalmente para no hacer
toda la cuenta de la suma es una suma
sencilla entonces tenemos que es igual a
un medio 2 y 5 tenemos que es igual a 7
luego por esta parte 3 más 7 es igual a
10 y nuestros puntos 25 nos dan 10
puntos 5 pues punto 25.25 es punto 5 más
los 7 que llevábamos es igual a 17.5 por
un medio tenemos que este resultado es
igual a 8.75 que es nuestra aproximación
al área bajo la curva sin olvidar que
estamos omitiendo las áreas de color
rosita que tenemos por aquí y al estar
las omitiendo pues simplemente tenemos
una aproximación más
cálculo exacto de dicha área por lo cual
dicha área estará subestimada pero es
una buena aproximación en estos próximos
vídeos trataremos de generalizar todas
estas situaciones donde tengamos una
función arbitraria un número arbitrario
de rectángulos y no precisamente nos
fijemos en el extremo izquierdo o límite
izquierdo de los rectángulos o es más
puede ser cualquier figura nos vemos en
el siguiente vídeo